vous posez les questions telles que
qu'est ce que j'adore c'est que ça je
peux faire ça de 8h à 10h au total si tu
as d'autres questions tu poses de [ __ ] à
leur jeu donc on va faire du cinéma
alors attention tu nous diras si c'est
vrai on le saura normalement elle nous
l'a fait qu'on s'y est fait du cinéma
bhattarai on va la recevoir si toi tu te
tais toi tu as tu m'aimes plus tôt
monsieur fils est parti vous êtes ma
passion à l'élu question bonjour je
m'appelle françoise la semaine dernière
j'ai appris que matthieu delormeau
allait présenter aux deux je trouve ça
super mais je suis un peu inquiète
est il nécessaire d'avoir vu le 1 pour
comprendre la suite
le renvoi soeur françoise et les pages
et cette angoisse pas beaucoup
téléspectateurs car c'est vrai qu'à la
fin de wouf 1 a vu un gros suspense
citobi allait réussir à monter sur la
balançoire on se refusait pas je passais
sportowy que je pars d'un chat pas de
l'ancien assistant de mathieu donc vous
rassure a priori ça sera pas une suite
d'un reboot 1 les deux histoires seront
indépendantes avec un nouveau casting de
l'andorre salle en poils en tout cas
c'est vrai à mathieu la semaine dernière
il a été gâté pour son anniversaire
harry car ce que vous savez pas c'est
qu'il n'a pas reçu que ce cadeau non
abbassi par ce coup alors je vous
racontais à segré il est né cinq je suis
né le 6 et 13 ans tim ans il s'appelle
m'a appelé mardi 6 pour me demander ce
que je voulais qu'elle m'offre même me
l'acheter même dit tu t'achètes et jeta
prétoire en bourse
bon j'ai été très touché mais j'ai
refusé évidemment observe j'étais gêné à
vous ne savez pas par contre c'est qu'il
avait fait la même proposition à
matthieu delormeau
andré
[Musique]
wattrelos
[Applaudissements]
la partie n'a pas fait ça adorable ok
voyant est ce qu'il a fait ou est ce
qu'il n'a pas fait pas encore alors
est-ce avocats de l'ancien patron
d'accor délaissé jean-luc continué en
mai après chaque émission choix qui lui
taxer aussi un peu d'argent de poche
alors regarde la vision d'ailleurs
j'étais chez moi mardi j'ai appris que
j'avais gagné un prime est un cadeau de
camille alors j'ai toujours pas vu ni
l'un ni l'autre n'ont la a donc vous
m'offrez ce que vous m'aviez déjà offert
avant oui d'accord c'était ok mais
est-ce qu'il y en aura d'autres après
encore ok donc je n'ai pas de cadeau ces
deux-là des poires il y en a plein mais
du coup d'oeil à ce que le cas de
camille je n'aime pas ce qu'ils avaient
dans la petite boîte de camille
heureusement que j'allais of ouest aucun
combat les tarifs mais il a déjà offert
son cadeau à jean luc lemoine il est là
c'est prêt
est ce que la pièce de jean-michel va
marcher
la pièce de théâtre marche déjà pu voir
ce qu'elle va s'arrêter là et continue
mais elle change de vieux change de lieu
d'accord travers le plus grand au plus
petit est un des vrais infos plus
important de la bière en plein air sur
la place c'est vrai bravo bravo très
banalement q je mets en dérapage en fait
pas on avait remarqué jean luc cottyn
mosquée ça la fait rire
julien est donc dans une petite boîte
comme ça il ya un moulage de monde et
les gens sont très naïve qu'elle dans
cette équipe enfin vraiment ils prennent
tous au premier degré gilles verdez par
exemple quand cyril fait un compliment à
tarek boudali il croit que c'est une
info vous savez que tarek boudali tarek
bouteille ouais jolie darrigues ou
d'alice et le patron du cinéma français
il a appelé les deux films les plus
rentables
ya pas marqué patrouille a marqué par
trois journalistes aussi on a maxime
gainey qui au sommet de la pyramide de
la naïveté alors s'il avait fait un
combinant un patrick timsit en lui
disant que pour lui c'était l'équivalent
de m pokora
voilà c'est la gueule comme compliment
pour patrice ils devaient être contents
c'est la suite qui est moins brillante
avec maxime qui va croire une info de
jean-michel regarder sa tête à la fin il
est pas bien et voilà tu es toujours -
pourquoi sache le il lui manquait
tatouage en est
[Musique]
et de plus en plus lourd à pas se mentir
on a un problème avec le garçon quand
même sympa le premier du deuxième degré
niveau humour maxime les croyants mais
pas pratiquants est-ce que vous ayez
qu'on passe au top sur un cadeau à huy
cette petite compilation des moments
étranges de tpm p
[Musique]
la télé réalité est ce qu'on a une
candidate des marseillais avoir de
grosses lacunes
[Musique]
les
le sol
[Musique]
six ans au collège qu'on a en beauté
merci
[Musique]
et
bonjour
[Musique]
ce soir a lieu les césar le singe
oui et ça y est oui mais césar alors et
c'est alors on va faire un petit sondage
alors dit moi et briques oui oui c'est
alors le trophée va pas très bien
[Musique]
pour tirer le signal là on a enlevé
effectivement le signal de tf1 et les
chaînes puisque pas si nombreux
[Musique]
la sûreté etc
et
à voir canal et la centaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
inutile j'avais déjà il faut que joue
par des mensonges maintenant je sais que
vous n'aimez pas ça mais là où vous avez
droit à la vérité
alors j'aurai le droit la vérité là et
j'aurai droit j'espère la vérité tout à
l'heure sur la sphère ke 2 ny également
sur laquelle je reviendrai dans un
instant alors lors d'une émission agathe
avait dit qu'elle n'avait aucun avis
dans l'équipe à part maximin et cyril
vous dire elle a menti
non il ya aussi mathieu un nom enfin les
deux ils sont comme ça
voilà alors ses meetings on sent que sa
fille en bisous tout ça
je
[Musique]
samedi
des personnes
[Musique]
et vous allez finir par vous aimez les
comédies romantiques d'albums tubize
soutien
[Applaudissements]
et à vous mais rien à voir non mais ça
aussi il à douala alors ça pique à terre
agression sur un mannequin ça va paulo
est ce que ça vaut bien un petit secret
de fabrication
et là je vais revenir sur le nouveau
regard de jean michel maire parce que je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué depuis
quelques jours quelque chose a changé
quand il pose les yeux sur vous non pas
si c'est très net hebinger l'explication
en fait tout a commencé par une vanne
que les téléspectateurs n'avaient
heureusement pas entendu à l'antenne il
nous raconte t il sans jeff bezos le
fondateur d'amazon parce qu'il est comme
ça si réussie vos histoires est un grand
h
il a quelques lacunes mais quand il
s'agit des biographies des mecs qui ont
fait fortune alors c'est moi une liste
de tout ce qui peut gagner de l'argent
sur internet donc le mec hyper tennis
jamie et crayons des trucs adobe
n'importe quoi et à mon ennemi des
livres le gars y voit des livres il dit
bah tu sais quoi
eh ben les livres et bah c'est ce que je
vais faire dans ces notions il avait de
montluçon une explosion a raconté marc
dorcel par les fumées
marcel des véhicules mais c est quand
même c'est quand même un problème
attention 4e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais je suis la nouvelle stratégie selon
michel rapaces esserhane c'est
l'intimidation et j'avoue que c'est
impressionnant
alors pour que vous compreniez j'ai
décortiqué une action allait là mathieu
va chambrer maxime kenny jean michel va
hyperventiler immédiatement ce qui veut
dire celui qui réfléchit il va sortir
une vanne qui va surtout faire une
personne autour de la table 8 même plan
des intimidations
en fait on vitesse vous êtes le dernier
tu vois je dispose envie d'aller le voir
pas bon pas bon pas bon pas bon ou
mauvais longtemps après c'est bon c'est
mon rêve
c'est quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est devenu quel phénomène assure rôle
c'est normal bong est un peu plus doux
mais quand même tu es tu m'as tué alors
mais on a un peu parce qu'on peut juste
revoir ce que je peux pas juste revoir
pour le plaisir pour le kiff l'image de
michel la première ouais bien sûr pour
la première fois l'intimidation au
premier regard il est tombé le réclame
annoncé que c'est plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je répondais à son intimidation parce
qu'il m'a fait aimé pendant l'émission
je vous jure que c'est vrai nous
regardent même message est découpée ce
qui me fait ça oui c'est normal faire
cette amicale
aujourd'hui on se régale avec les quatre
tiers et il nous reste une petite
séquence monde adore qui s'appelle il y
en a un peu plus vous mais quand même
c'est pas bien commencer par ce jour
délicieux où cyril avait décidé de
désigner la mascotte de tpm et pour
l'occasion certains chroniqueurs étaient
venus avec leur animal de compagnie
[Musique]
dès mon bébé rossignon
battus
[Applaudissements]
dans les minimas c'était c'était en
train de regarder
il va nous dire vous allez voir ce
qu'ils vivent et où c'est parti
[Musique]
on est venu vers moi parce que j'ai
ressenti
[Musique]
mimie mathy soirs comme ça tout le monde
rigole isabelle morini bosc
il y fait draguer puis largué au milieu
d'un lac alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
un homme lucide on voulait montrer le
moment où scarlett a créé son avatar
pour choisir son style de mère idéale
des abdos un pack comme ça
[Musique]
c'est moi et j'ai la phobie du pas
mouillé ça c'est qu'ils disent à java
bien voilà phobie du pont d'issy
monsieur madame c'est à dire est ce que
m6 a demandé de l'argent aux autres très
intéressant m6 aurait eu ils sont pas
dans l'histoire alors intéressant tout a
commencé donc effectivement est ce que
c'est ça peut faire quelque chose doit
tuer ou pas alain c'est intéressant
parce que les monsieur madame vous êtes
régalés sur scène ou pas c'était très
bien et ont joué avec myriam el khomri
et roselyne bachelot soit remis en selle
plus collectif
[Applaudissements]
monsieur je crois qu'ils ont
d'initiative isole à mes toiles insu sur
le gentil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]